the incredible Alex the Benelli is
wonderful to see you
exciting right I mean she was
okay we are here
straight from telecon we have a tumor
what is it like to be a part of the
Marvel Universe oh my God unreal yeah
this is so unreal just yeah being here
finally getting here from from
production to everything and now oh my
God Pinch Me Pitch me please pinch me
okay I'm breathing we know you can't
tell us much but what can you tell us
about your character
such a such a such a special project you
know we all work so hard and making a
movie of this magnitude it's it's no
simple joke not at all you add
everything that's going on in the world
the pandemic it's even more difficult I
am very proud that we all came together
and we worked so hard to make this and
I'm excited for the fans who go see it
and then and you guys are gonna love
this because we work so hard for it
okay you talked about the process of
production but what was it like getting
the call that you are now a part of the
Marvel Universe it was like I got the
car and I was like
I call my mom
straight to voicemail I call my
girlfriend she didn't answer oh no and I
called my mom and she finally answered I
told her and then we're all you know
excited and we're here she's somewhere
around here and this isn't just any role
I mean you are a general of Neymar's
Army I can't say that I am a tumor yes I
am so so so excited that he's finally
here in MCU and people are gonna meet
he's a very
humble loving person he loves his people
but he's someone you don't want to mess
with you're pissed off yeah because
he'll attack you uh-oh Big Time uh-oh
we're on the IRS
I already have real fears I don't need
that in my movies too my friend
sometimes the hair make an underwater
appearance you know of course I want to
make this clear
atuma's hair is real
you heard it here first folks you heard
it here first well thank you so much
talking with us we can't wait to watch
her hair thank you so much guys
absolutely lovely to speak with you